So, one sort of exercise, this is back when I was a decent teacher, but this is a long
time ago, but one exercise that I did that maybe you can extract something from, I don't
know, is I would teach the enthymeme.
I just, like, here's what an enthymeme is, and I would teach the ubiquity of the enthymeme.
I'm like, look, there are enthymemes, like, every third thing someone says is an enthymeme,
and maybe even every other thing that someone says, and I would teach, like, the simple way
of recognizing is the word because, like, you know, that's the easy way, like, such and
such and such because of, like, you, there's an enthymeme.
So, I would, what I would have them do is if they could point out, if someone in class
said something, and it's all, the beginning of class is what it always happened.
What did you guys think of the reading?
It was really boring.
It's like, ah, enthymeme, like, and a student would call out, there's an enthymeme.
I didn't like it because it was boring.
And, and then the student who had said, the student who had said the enthymeme has to now
make it into a syllogism, right?
Like, that was the, so that was the exercise.
It's like, someone points out, like, oh, I heard an enthymeme, and then the student
who said it has to now unpack it into an enthymeme.
And what would happen if, if it's a comment of any interest at all, which is easy to come
up with, is that, oh my gosh, you actually made an argument, even though you never thought
of it as an argument.
You just said, I thought the reading was boring.
And it's like, well, there's an argument implicit as you unpack the enthymeme.
And so, so by expanding it from the kind of the black box that is an enthymeme into something
more formalized, like a syllogism, you realize, oh, there's a whole series of like seven steps,
not just the Socrates mortal thing, but like, here's what I consider to be good.
Good count must be interesting.
Interesting things are more informative.
And that, you know, like the whole series of steps, even just by saying the reading was
boring, that you unpack and they go like, oh my God, I didn't realize there was a whole
argument in there.
And I'm like, yeah, that's how arguments work.
They, you know, they work in this truncated form by not telling you what they are.
So that was a way into, I wasn't explicitly teaching logos.
I was really just teaching them to recognize the recurrence of enthymematic thinking in everyday
kind of relance.
But it was an exercise that I think was pretty useful.
Like they, they got good at like recognizing it.
We got to a point where we had to call a moratorium because it was like, really, every third sentence
wasn't an enthymeme.
You know, like, okay, enthymeme in this, enthymeme, we didn't have time to do anything else.
Right.
Well, imagine, yeah.
I love that.
I mean, and that's, that plays into the way that I want to think about all of these rhetorical
concepts is really emphasize their inventive power and not treat, you know, logos as the,
you know, quality checking sort of thing, which ends up being totally paralyzing for students.
Because they go like, I can't, everything I write is wrong.
It's this or that fallacy.
So I can't write anything.
So, and then, I mean, you, what you could, what you could do with that is as you unpack
the enthymeme, you could be pointing out the various associational structures between the
six points that they had presumed.
Right.
Like, so, ah, that's a causal argument.
Ah, that's an argument from origin.
Ah, that's an, you know what I mean?
Like, so the, the, the things that are linking them and you try, try it in a classroom and
shit's going to come out.
I mean, it's, it's a really easy exercise to get them thinking.
And they, I mean, it just rolled from the couple of times that I did it.
Like it just rolled, it was super easy to do.
And, and it just like, you'll take up whole class periods where you'll just end up filling,
filling and rolling.
And as you're unpacking them, and if you could come up with, like, I wasn't really paying
attention to what are the means of the association.
I simply wanted them to recognize the truncated argument and to elongate it.
It's like, oh my God, you actually just wrote a paper in your comment in response to the
reading and you didn't realize it, right?
Like you now have an argument and reasons that you didn't realize that you'd, you'd
had, right?
This also, this reminds me a little bit of some of our conversations about taste, because
you're saying like the initial enthymeme is usually like, well, I didn't like this, you
know, and how many arguments are basically rooted initially in a, in a taste.
You know, a question of taste.
And it's like, you know, there's obviously then a structure to taste and to preference.
And like, you know, you would think of taste as being associated with pathos, right?
Or an emotional sort of relation to the text.
But then clearly it's also structured by a bunch of other relationships that you have.
Like, you know, so I, I think that's, that's also a good way to, to get them.
Cause a lot of students can't get past the, I don't like this or I like this thing.
Right.
It's like you, you, what you want them to do is, yeah.
I think that too is going to disrupt the, the supposedly subjective position of the, of
the taste.
That's right.
Right.
As soon as you unpack the enthymeme, it's like suddenly you find the general principles
that you're expecting everyone else.
Right.
We're into Kant's third critique.
Yeah.
The other thing with the enthymeme too is like the, the, what you talked about the
enthymeme game is like it, you have to call a moratorium on it because it just expounds
it's like, yeah, like, I mean, this is the same, you, you get to the same conclusion when
you start analyzing, you know, the syllogism is that as soon as you start having to make
the steps in between the gaps and propositions that will proliferate itself, that proliferates
itself infinitely.
And like what you find Aristotle really arguing for is not that the, the enthymeme is a weakened
version of the syllogism.
It's that the enthymeme is actually a version of the syllogism that doesn't fall into Zeno's
paradox that it can actually move.
It can, it can actually, like enthymemes can actually live.
Syllogisms can't get off the ground if you're going to be strict with them.
And I like pointing to like one line syllogisms too.
Yeah.
I mean, you know, I like this one, but, and I'm going to have to retire this one soon because
I just hope I can retire it.
But the make America great, Mike Mag is an enthymeme that, you know, is unpacks itself
in a variety of ways that that is really powerful.
I mean, because it doesn't matter what you fill those blanks in with.
Like, you know, it was like America was great.
Now it's not great.
And it needs to be made great again.
What happened?
Who did this?
Who's to blame?
Now suddenly anger gets imported.
It doesn't matter who you fill the blank, the blank.
Right.
Yeah.
So one last thing I was just going to say that for all of, also all of Aristotle's like
worry that pathos is the sort of controlling of the most controlling or most dominant of
the pistis and the desire to sort of like introduce logos as the regulator.
His argument for why the enthymeme is so powerful ends up coming down to pathos because it is
the feeling of being able to participate in, yeah, in, in the, the making of the syllogism process.
Yeah.
It's not just me being told what to do.
It's the, it is like a, the argument becomes like a third party to the both of us, you know,
and as long as I can work myself through it, I feel more confident.
Right.
I also don't really understand how you wouldn't speak in enthymemes.
Like imagine speaking syllogistically, it would sound ridiculous.
I mean, like what, how would you never, yeah, yeah.
It would be infinitely right.
Right.
Yeah.
It would sound, it would sound way too formal and strange.
But, but also, I mean, this actually very much does relate to the Deleuze stuff because,
you know, what, what you were saying there in terms of his understanding of the syllogism,
it's very platonic.
The implication that there are a series of distinct logical points implicit that the reader is
completing assumes that logic is that foundational ground, whether it's spoken or not, as opposed
to, right, like in, for Deleuze, it's like, no, what connects those things is something
like sense, right?
It's not, it's not logical.
It's not a series of predications that have been sort of not made explicit, but are nevertheless
exist somewhere, right, in, in the, in the world of logic within the statement.
So it just, you know, I mean, obviously Aristotle's a student, but it has that implication that
the notion that you're completing an enthymeme and that's what makes it powerful, even though
it sounds like a pathos appeal, it's actually a deep, deeply idealistic logos appeal, you know,
except for that I get to feel, no, no, no, because I get to feel that I'm participating in a movement
of logos, you know, that, that I am completing.
So I am part of this, this world that has this series of incredibly logical steps that are
never made explicit and never stated outright, but are nevertheless there.
Right.
So, uh, that's why the, the, the draw of pathos is an implicit logical series.
And there's also, there's also the supposition that there is, there are complete and sort of
final syllogisms that guide the speech or the argument.
When in reality, the enthymeme is suggestive of thousands of associations and depending on
who's receiving it, you're going to make those different, that's not going to be the same
syllogism for every audience member.
I mean, this is where it's like, you know, logic or metaphor, right?
Those are your choices.
Right.
And do you believe in this sort of paratactic movement of metaphor or the hypotactic movement
of logic?
Are you an analytic philosopher or a continental philosopher?
Right.
Are you Nietzsche or Russell?
Are you, you know, I mean, this is right.
And if you read what, which, which Derrida is it?
White, not white noise.
That's Don DeLillo.
White mythology.
Then you like uncover the metaphor.
The metaphor of metaphor.
Which logic.
Right.
Yeah.
The metaphor of metaphor.
Right.
But I was going to say too, that this, like the paralyzing feature of the
syllogism is precisely why the, the, the unique, um, disease of, of Plato is, is mania.
Right.
Is that, I mean, in infinite ascent, infinite, the ironic ascent of, of always like moving
to the next matter term that's going to find, you know, I want to understand what the fuck
the word irony means here, by the way, like that it's just really, because I mean, I, I
really felt like I kind of knew what irony was and I just feel super confused about
what irony, I mean, I understand here, I know, I know what Socratic irony is like, I'm clear
on that.
It's, you know, he pretends that he doesn't know when in fact he knows, but I think that's
a really, a very stupid, but a very kind of, yeah.
Like, well, just a questionable reading of the Platonic dialogues.
Like, cause to me all along, I'm like, yes, I understand that Socrates seems like he is
Columbo.
Right.
Um, but I, I'm willing to give Plato the benefit of the doubt and be like, no, Socrates doesn't
think he knows.
Like he really, really doesn't.
It's not like he has this sort of secret understanding of things that he's not letting on about and
he's sort of doing his, like, cause that's what Columbo does.
Right.
And people, you know, Columbo is like, well, he seems like this sort of stumbling, bumbling
idiot guy, but he's actually super tuned in.
It's like, I don't think that's Socrates at all.
I think Socrates actually doesn't know, but whatever.
I understand that that's what people mean by Socratic irony.
But in this case, I don't understand irony as that form of ascent.
You know, and I, obviously I'm talking about this sort of humor chapter, right?
That he wants to say, you know, irony is like humor is the return to the surfaces where irony
is the, is the movement of ascent.
And I don't really know what irony means there anymore, but I don't know a lot of things mean
there.
Well, when we say this, first off, whether or not Socrates does or does not really know,
like, forget about that.
It's just so much more interesting.
If you assume he doesn't know, if you don't presume Socratic irony and you're actually
following him through the thinking, it just becomes so much more interesting.
As soon as you posit the Socratic irony, it's just like, ah, this statement doesn't count.
This statement doesn't count.
You're just waiting for the hammer to drop.
The whole pedagogy of the dialectic becomes meaningless, right?
It's just, or rather it simply becomes an opportunity to show the idiot that he's an idiot, right?
That's all that happens in the dialogues then.
And it's like, well, it seems to me like, why would you bother writing 40 of those?
Right?
Like maybe, maybe one, cause it's funny, you know, to make, make fun of the carpenter or
the whatever.
But like, why would you write those all the time unless it was an actual inquiry, right?
Like, I've got, I don't think this section is going to make the thing, but I kind of wanted
to, but the first line is nothing serves the fantasy of propositional content with greater
loyalty than the notion of Socratic irony.
That's, that's the starting statement of that.
No, say that, say that one again.
I got to catch up to it.
Nothing serves the fantasy of propositional content with greater loyalty than the notion of
Socratic irony.
Yeah.
Right.
There's a truth to that irony, right?
Yeah.
No, no, no.
But the irony is not there.
The irony is not there.
You know, if the irony is there, if you read Socrates as disingenuously pretending that
he doesn't know what knowledge is, what virtue is, what truth is, all of those things, and
simply, you know, leading the person into a dead end in which they are confronted with
an aporia, it's a way less interesting operation than if, you know, he, if Socrates doesn't
know, actually, he's being simply sincere.
I don't know what virtue is.
Let's, let's submit ourselves both in this interlocution to the method of dialectic in
order to go somewhere.
And how would you understand, how would you understand dialogues like the Sophist where
he says repeatedly, it doesn't matter what answer you give.
You just need to answer, right?
So we can keep doing this.
Right.
Yeah.
Like the way that gets within the Socratic ironic sort of paradigm, the way that gets
interpreted as that, like, is you, you're, you're going to get to the right answer.
You're going to get to the propositional like place of solidity.
So like, where does that happen in the Platonic dialogues?
Where's a Platonic dialogue in which they arrive at, here's what virtue is.
Here's what, look, I mean, it never happens.
And then what usually happens is somebody finds something they'd like, and then they
hypostasize it, and then they ignore everything else that undercuts us, right?
And usually it's like two thirds of the way through the dialogue where they seem to arrive
at something and they're like, ah, but then they didn't continue to question it.
That's, that's where we're at.
Like the movement doesn't matter.
And if, but like presuming Socratic irony makes the movement not matter at all, which
is, as you said, that's the whole pedagogy.
So I just don't get, I mean, I understand, I also know that it's just a phrase that people
say, right?
Socratic irony and whatever.
It doesn't necessarily have to adhere actually.
Like I can't imagine that people who do philosophy work today with Plato actually believe in Socratic
irony.
I mean, it just doesn't, it does, it isn't very interesting.
So that's one version of irony, right?
Like the disjunction between the expressed and the intention, right?
So, okay, I get that.
I understand.
And I thought that's what irony was, right?
But then I read the stuff on humor and I'm like, I don't know what irony is anymore.
I don't really understand what he means by irony here.
So, so this is the way that I took that.
And this is one, something that like, it comes and it goes as I'm trying to work my way through
It.
But I mean, so irony is, is a movement of ascent, right?
And it's always the meta move or the, the, the move of transcendence to find the rule that
governs over the interplay between the two things.
So in the case of Socratic irony, the rule that governs over the, the, the Socrates not
knowing and the characters not knowing is the secrecy of Socrates really knowing, right?
And that becomes like this meta move that, that is determining the relationship between
its two propositions.
And that, so that ironic, I think the way that he's seeing irony is the properly Platonic
movement is, doesn't really have much to do with that dramatic form of irony, but has
more to do with a philosophical irony, wherein any set of prop, like particulars as being governed,
like the, the movement mean needs to be to find the transcendent rule that is governing the
thing, which then takes on its own particularness and then needs to find the rule.
Okay. So we've, but we've just been talking about that in the previous weeks as the general,
like the general particular dialectic then. So it's just a movement to the general, which
then becomes its own particular in relationship to another general.
But it's not historical progress. Like we were talking about with, with Hegel, that this
is much more of a, the chronological movement. There's no chronological movement of it, which
is why it's mania, which is why it is, you know, the infinite ascent in the moment of, you
know, like any snapshot of, of, of a concept, you know, you move indefinitely to the pure
vacuity of the form, right? Of the forms of the eidos, which ends up, and the way that
he's like, I mean, you're thinking of the 19th series, right? On, on humor.
Yeah. The humor one. Yeah.
Right. The way that I see it there is, is, you know, the, in trying to find the, um, uh,
the, the, the, the, the, the, the stabilization point between, you know, manifestation, denotation
and signification. Right.
Plato wants to root it in signification, like the rules that are, that, that, and so you,
you get that movement from there.
The idea, the idea will give you, I mean, in theory, the idea will give you the ground.
It will give you the ground that creates the relationship between the manifestation and denotation.
Right. And then Christophus, you know, answers with the, the nonsensical quick answer to show
the way that denotation can be attached to signification and manifestation in ways that
frustrate the supposed primacy of signification. Does that make sense?
Say that again. Say that one right again.
So Christophus' response were like, you know, the response to the, Plato's description of the,
the human as the featherless biped and he holds up a chicken or something.
Diogenes, yeah.
That's Diogenes.
That was, that was throwing me.
Yeah, sorry, sorry.
But Christophus is the one who says the chariot, like the chariot thing.
Like when I say chariot, it comes through.
Yeah.
But the response there is to show that, you know, in articulating, like, so, so signification
creates its categories, right?
It's vertical relationships between, between general and specific, and it tries to create
an order there.
And what Deleuze is trying to get at is that, you know, manifestation and denotation are not
just species of that, of, of, or not just subject to signification.
Signification, right.
Right.
And the way of, and the way that the Stoics demonstrate that the non-primacy of signification
is to show that, that denotations can be attached to manifestations and significations in ways
that do not agree with the order of the signification.
In ways that do not agree with the order.
Okay.
So in other words, that there are other.
Which is why they appear nonsensical.
Right.
Which is why they appear like, you know, you ask me about virtue and I, like, masturbate
in public.
Right.
Hence the.
The connection there is now governed by signification.
Right.
And yet there is still a connection.
The denotation is still getting attached to, right.
Right.
Well, and that's, that's where the speed thing, I mean, it's like, and that's, that's
one of my favorite parts of that segment.
It's like, you got to do it fast and you do it fast for the simple reason that you don't
want it to be governed by the idea or by signification.
You just like, just say something, right.
Don't, don't say the right thing or don't say the clever thing.
Just fucking say something.
And as, as a way of interrupting that governance by the idea and, and the notion of assent that
is implicit.
Okay.
I kind of get a handle on that a little bit.
I kind of think about it.
Like how, so like irony, irony seems to proliferate, proliferate in only like one kind of way.
And it's that kind of assent way.
Right.
But humor proliferates.
Like, so when Diogenes does his performance art, there are all kinds of things that are
invented out of that moment.
Right.
Um, it's kind of like, I feel like Socrates has one moment where he does this, where it's,
it's actually really, it's, it's, it's very profound that that moment in, in the Gorgias
where he's asked, like, do you prefer, like, what would you prefer to suffer harm or to
do harm?
And he has that moment where he says, I, I would prefer neither.
And then of course he's like, well, but obviously to be a part of the polis, you have to, you
have to do this.
So then he chooses.
Right.
But that's, there's that moment where there's like a, there's an, another option, you know?
And I feel like humor is that other option.
And irony is just the, the one-to-one, like the ascent.
Right.
So, because I think of that as the, I think of that as the Bartleby move, right?
Yes.
Yes, exactly.
Yeah.
But, but Bartleby would often be seen as being ironic.
Right.
I mean, the, the, the, the preferring not to is because he prefers something else.
He's just not telling you.
Right.
And that you have to do work on Bartleby, which Deleuze does to say, Bartleby's I prefer
not to is not ironic.
Right.
It's not a hit.
There's not a hidden thing that Bartleby would prefer to do.
He just doesn't want to do that.
Right.
I mean, I, I mean, just, you know, but this is the way I understand the connection between
the way that we typically think of dramatic or literary irony and the way that we're thinking
he's thinking about it philosophically here is that, you know, in, in any kind of literary
or dramatic irony, there's always the, the, the, um, the meta-reflective rule that governs,
you know, the, the mere aporia or the mere appearance of, of some kind of, you know, of some sort
of statements or all like you say this, but be like, but, but above that, that, that
layer, there's the, the governing, you know, consciousness that means something other than
what they said.
Right.
Yeah.
The philosophical project is like, look, this is the, this is the appearance that, you know,
that, that orders, it seems to be ordered this kind of way, but there's a, a transcendent
rule that is distributing.
Right.
So, but the, so the issue is how to get, so, I mean, cause the way that I would understand
is the problem with, is there in that formulation of it is with the idea of meaning and saying
being different things.
Right.
So the, the holding onto that disjunction.
So whatever I say, I actually mean something else in relation to it.
If you got rid of, and I think that's the point of the speed, if you get rid of the notion
of meaning, then it's just saying, right.
A saying and another saying and another saying.
So they all, which are still linked to each other, they are not governed by the transcendence.
Right.
That would be the romantic.
But why is that, why is that, it's signification because it's organized by the idea?
Cause to me, that sounds like manifestation or at least how he talks about manifestation,
right?
Like manifestation is the expression of, you know, of me.
Right.
So the mean.
But categories still function, right.
But they just don't function vertically.
I think that's where he's going to end up getting to.
But the thing with speed is that, you know, he's got, there are, there are two responses
of there's this, the speed with which one points out the denotation to disrupt the, or
makes the denotative move to disrupt the signifying move.
Right.
That's one thing, but that doesn't point to the surface.
So, so, I mean, he, he talks about speed on two different pages on 135, 135, and again
136.
And they're, and they're in two different, two different ways.
Right.
Because the first one, the first speed is purely destructive.
It throws us into the ground.
Right.
It throws us into the, into the undifferentiated ground.
I love this.
That's right.
Right.
By the way, the destructive and especially this word, digestive ground.
Yeah.
Like, I mean, this is the Dionysian oneness.
You know, the unity of, of, of, of all being.
And by just simply destroying signification's capacity to order, uh, like that then throws
everything into turmoil.
Right.
That is the pure, that is a, it is a nihilistic act.
But then there's the second speed that, that, that brings things to the surface wherein there's
not the transcendent signification that is bearing down on it.
And there's not the simple eradication of order, but there are the contingent high, like singular, like
high seities that create voluntary orders between this and that.
And then this and that, like, and this is, I took me a long time to figure out the, the
Zen, um, you know, if you have a, if, if you have a, uh, Zen versus the Brahmin or the
Buddhist, right?
The Zen is the surface one of just the problem, the problems test.
But, uh, because that's just maps on cleanly onto the Stoics, pre-Socratics and, and, and
Claytonists.
It's the, if you have a King says the Zen master, I'm going to give you one.
If you do not have one, I'm taking it away.
Um, or as Chrysippus says, if you'd ever lost something, you still have it, but if you've
never lost horns, ergo, you, you have horns and like from the level of signification, those
don't make sense, right?
They're not, they, they, they breach good sense, right?
And they breach common sense, but they don't throw you simply into the digestive ground.
If you follow through the orders that they instantiate on the surface, that it is not
simply the removal of, of, of, of order that there isn't now a, an idiosyncratic or a
singular or like, um, relationship between the having and not having the King and, uh, you
know, um, uh, that having and not having the horns that can like set like sense is getting
articulated there, but not along the transcendent route.
You can make sense out of that.
The negation no longer expresses anything negative in the realm of signification, but rather releases
the expressible with its two uneven halves.
One of the halves is always lacking from the other since it exceeds it by virtue of its own
deficiency, even if this means to be deficient by virtue of that word equals X for thing
equals X.
The Zen art, the drawing example.
So across the abolished significant, signification and the lost denotations, the void is the site
of sense or of the event which harmonizes with its own nonsense in the, uh, in, in the place
where the, uh, place only takes place.
So the void becomes itself a paradoxical element.
It's not an absence or it's not an absence or lack.
Yeah.
It is the surface on which singularities get coordinated.
And I mean, when you think about singularities, I don't, I feel like sometimes, at least for
me, I feel like I get really, really close to it.
And then it just like, like I get close to kind of understanding or following through
the line and then it just fucking falls apart every time.
And I go like, I'm, I'm totally confused about every single word in that sentence all
of a sudden.
Right.
So I, I, so in other words, I'm doing the, the previous version of speed, which is denotation
in turn precipitates us into destructive and digestive ground based on the nonsense with
the depths of subset, right?
Like where it's just like, uh, undifferentiated ground.
It's all exhausted.
Right.
Well, the way he's talking about the, the void here seems ironic, ironically, uh, to be
more of a multiplicity, right?
I mean, it's sort of a standard Deleuzian paradox is like, that's, that's the site
of humor, at least the way I'm taking it in this chapter.
Right.
So that it's not the site of irony or at least of a Socratic irony, right.
Where, where everything is resolved under the, the truthful proposition that's like just
simply delayed in the ironic statement, you know, um, I was just curious what you guys thought
because I wasn't exactly following, um, the conversation early, a little bit earlier, just
about the dynamics of irony.
Like we're, we're, we trying to outline romantic irony also, or were we kind of focusing mostly
because he does that.
I don't even know the difference.
I don't even know what romantic irony is.
Like even just sort of conversationally, I don't know what it is.
Right.
I mean, I don't know what it is generally, but for Deleuze, it seems to be at least more
complex than Socratic irony, the way he's setting up the categories, you know?
So, I mean, that's the person, the individual versus the person thing, which that throws me
back to that Logical Genesis stuff that I'm like.
Yeah.
I mean, my, my, my understanding is that the romantic irony would be kind of, you know,
in the line of Hegel, right?
Where the, the one is presupposed, subjectivity is kind of required, but it's still, it's, it's
a more complex process, right?
So, you know, you're talking about like with, with the standard Socratic irony, you don't
mean what you say, but you, you could, you could mean what you say.
You're just not doing that in romantic irony.
I don't think you ever mean what you say.
It's just, it's like, it's like difference basically at some level.
It's like a constant deferral of meaning without a recuperation of the original propositional
content.
Yet this still relies on the presupposition that there is a unified subject that is unraveled.
Right.
So that's why for Deleuze.
So the meta move would be romantic irony.
Exactly.
The classic, I mean, that's not Socratic irony, that's romantic irony.
Like I am talking about the fact that I am making, writing a book as I'm writing the book.
Right.
Yeah, exactly.
And that's why he wants to get past that obviously.
Cause he's not just completely in line with like idealism or, you know, enlightenment thinking
or romantic thinking, you know?
So, um, but yeah, anyway, I had trouble trying to parse out the difference between, um, the
individual and the, and the personal, the person, yeah, that was odd.
Right.
So like this is Montaigne and or so, right.
That, I mean, the way, what I, what I do understand is that, you know, the, the individual is running
along the general particular route, right.
That the individual is sort of like marked by, by, um, traits of the species or traits of,
right.
And then, and so the individual, despite the name, the individual can be quite generic
is in fact, yeah, it is necessarily generic.
Yeah.
Right.
And, and, you know, and somehow Montaigne, uh, uh, sets that, sets that out by that the
person, which is so grounded on the genericness of the individual, like becomes far more, maybe,
maybe, maybe idiosyncratic rather than singular is the right way to talk about it.
Right.
But that particular, particular, particular, yeah.
Particular.
Well, doesn't particular still run along a general specific.
Yeah.
Line.
I just think of individual as the general and person is the particular.
That's my simple oversimplified way maybe, but he said, I mean, in the previous one, there
are two ones previous where he says the individual is an infinite analytic proposition, whereas
the person is a, uh, is a finite synthetic proposition.
So, I mean, analytic, and that's in the super conventional sense of analytic, which is that
it contains its definition within itself, right?
Like it is by definition, this thing, whereas synthetic is, it relates to the actual world.
So that's where, to me, I always thought of person as being what we mean by a person and
individual being a category placeholder that any given person, you know, um, occupies.
I mean, sort of maybe general way of talking about this to say like the individual was sort
of like the sum of their identity positions, you know, like all of them, not exactly.
Right.
But then the person is the, the, the, the, the, the synthetic of them in the world.
Yeah.
You could, you might, including the context.
And he, he even gives these coordinates, but the, the individual, the way we're talking
about it could be like the cogito as well as like a general category of subjectivity.
Whereas the person would be the kind of differentiated, distributed subject, the located subject.
Descartes would be a person.
The cogito would be an individual.
Exactly.
I'm getting, I mean, that's, that's just my, again, like, I don't know if that's a good
take or not.
I mean, it works for me right now.
He mentions the cogito here as a sort of precursor.
Yeah.
That it takes Kant to sort of lift that up a little bit, the cogito up a little bit
and to, and to start thinking of it in terms of personhood.
Right.
Cause it makes sense.
So, I mean, if you, if you think of the difference between Montaigne's Essays and Rousseau's Confessions,
like, you know, Rousseau's Confessions are personal in ways that the Essays aren't.
Right.
So I, I get that sense from the difference between the two is that the person is personal.
Whereas, you know, it's, it is, it is the I, not the function of the I, but my saying
I, right.
Is the personal part.
Um, but, but how is, then how is the romantic irony?
If I'm understanding romantic irony as the meta move, which by the way is always enjoyable,
right?
Like who doesn't like the good, a good meta move.
Like if that's the realm of the person.
Yeah.
Right.
Isn't that, that's the, that's the, uh, basically.
Yeah.
So the position of the person is an unlimited class, uh, which nevertheless only has one
member, such as romantic irony.
Um, there are already precursive elements in the Cartesian cogito and above, above all in
the live Nietzschean person.
But these elements remain subordinate to the demands of individuation.
Whereas romanticism following Kant, they liberate and express themselves for their own sake, overthrowing
their subordination.
Right.
So, you know, it's just emphases on like the dynamics of the subject.
Like for, for Descartes, it's the transparent subject.
There's total confidence in it.
He's the master subject basically.
And then for Kant that it's kind of dissolved a little bit or it's less, it's less of a strict,
the subject is an unattainable ideal that you never reach.
For Descartes, it is what you're, that is what you have all the time is that ideal.
Yeah.
So, but what all the figures of irony have in common is they can find, this is after that
block quote on 139.
That's Kierkegaard, that block.
The Kierkegaard.
What, what all the figures of irony have in common is that they can find singularity within
the limits of the individual or the person.
So irony only operates through recourse to, again, I think of it in terms of the general
or, or specific, which is to say up and down.
Right.
But I would say for, for both of those, they're, they're not, the, the, the person isn't specific
to the individual, even though the person is grounded on, on the individual, but that these
are just two styles of verticality, right?
That, the, the, that the individual is the verticality of, you know, the individual to
species to, to, to, to, I mean, that taxonomical version, whereas the, the, the, which is one
kind of meta move, right?
It's one kind of transcendence, but personal irony is a different kind of transcendence that
it actually moves ref, like reflectively, reflectively, right?
Well, self-reflectiveness would be the term.
Yeah, yeah.
Right.
So rather than moving up the categorical chain, it's receding into the layers of, of the
self, of my self-reflecting on myself, reflecting on myself, reflecting on myself, right?
Okay.
Yeah.
So it's like, it's the transcendence of looking into a hall of mirrors of like, you know, you
know, the, the infinite regressive.
Okay.
I, okay.
That's a good, I just didn't distinguish between the, cause to me, I, but I see the difference
between a meta move in that sense and self-reflection then.
So, you know.
But they're both meta moves, right?
They're both meta moves.
I just, right.
I didn't distinguish between them.
Right.
There's still something like, I guess, egoistic or egotistical about the, the romantic ironic
stance for, for Deleuze.
And that's why humor, I guess, disrupts that, right?
It's not, it's not predicated on an individual being dispersed.
There is just, the individual is a moment.
Well, but, and that totally makes sense to me.
Like most of the comedy that I like is of the romantic ironic kind in that regard.
Right.
Insofar as Chris Rock or Chappelle, you know, like these folks are sort of the masters of
sort of their reflection being a dimension of the, of the comedy that they're making.
But nevertheless, that's why they are masters, right?
They are, you know, they are geniuses because they have this, they have internalized within
themselves this capacity for like three layers of meta moves in a statement, right?
As opposed to, in this case, humor would just be really like what, not in the terms used
here, but what we would just call nonsense, right?
Like in terms of it's just like, it doesn't, it just doesn't make sense.
Depends on what kind of humor it is, right?
Because it can be the slapstick humor where it's just like, and now it dissolves into nothingness,
into nonsense.
Right, yeah.
Or it can be the, the, the, the move out of left field where you're not making the brilliant
reflection about the nature of the thing.
I think it's the left field, the left field move is what he's interested in.
But creating the idiosyncratic relationship between the thing that you found in left field
and over here, right?
And that's, that's for him, the humor of, of, of the surface.
And I mean, so it's that next line.
So you, so right after that Kierkegaard quote, you read what all these figures of irony have
in common is that they can find the singularity within the limits of the individual or the
person.
Thus, irony only in appearance assumes the role of the vagabond.
And it's precisely the figure of the vagabond that he's going to say is, is humor, which is
the figure of Hercules, the Hercules that traverses the surface that doesn't find the
meta-reflective move that goes up into the sky that explains or reflects on the nature of the thing
at the surface, or goes into the depths and grounds the reality of the surface, but creates the
idiosyncratic link from this point on the surface to that point of the surface, which can be really
fucking funny.
Right.
And it doesn't presuppose individuation as the kind of primary foundation, right?
Humor doesn't do that.
Yeah.
Irony does, but, but humor doesn't do that.
And I also think that humor, I actually like, actually reading this section made me understand
why so many feminist philosophers use Deleuze actually, you know, like, so like Elizabeth
Gross and Erin Manning, like, I was like, I kind of understand now why Deleuze is used to
kind of critique, I mean, Plato for sure.
Um, from a kind of feminist angle, because humor seems to kind of insert the body and the
material back into the equation, whereas irony wants to kind of ascend from the material and
The laboring and the base.
Right.
Um, so I, I, I don't know.
I'm just like, I kind of understand feminist philosophy more like from this one section.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Well, I mean, that makes total sense to me because given the way that Deleuze is interested
in bodies as sort of bodies that are, that are formed on the surface.
So like the labor of the four, like one is given a body, right?
And who's given a body more than the, like the feminine body is given a body in a way that
the masculine body is just, you know, much more, doesn't exist.
Right.
And it does not escape me that these two sections, so the 18th section, the 19th section are the
first, we get a repetition of art of the surfaces, right?
So we get a real kind of like explicit, like I, I'm in some ways it's kind of like, this
is, this is a method or this is the invention.
Right.
And this, and the, and the section right before the 18th section, it feels like he's actually
putting into practice, like you have to, again, sense has to be both language and body, linguistic
and sensual.
Right.
And he's doing that with like, like the way, the visual, the visuals that he's giving to,
to philosophers that are like, like you just get like these very kind of,
visceral feeling of like description.
Right.
And that pre, and that precedes like this section, right.
We're, we're, we're taught that we have to have both of these things in motion.
But that's great.
Cause this version of the body can't be like the body verse, you know, the intelligence by
the body is the particular like combinations of, or, or mixtures that, that, you know, produce
the boundaries of this or that body.
But then totally, you know, it looks like so much of the, like return to the body scholarship
is sort of like return to the body as opposed to the intelligence or the ideal or whatever,
or whatever else.
And this, his take on the body is, is totally different.
Yes.
Which is why you can talk about things like toxic bodies and not talk about like little
biological toxic critters out there.
Right.
Whatever that would be.
For me, the hard part of thinking the thing that you got, I mean that the distinction you're
making there, I think is important, but like I have, I still have a hard time with, I totally
get why we don't want to do a scent.
Totally get it.
Right.
Like in terms of idealism and Plato's the figure for whatever, whatever the descent though.
Like, so in the, think in terms of the three images of philosophers, Nietzsche is the name
for the descent and the descent is inadequate for Deleuze.
Right.
So the version of one version of the descent, right.
That the sort of Dionysian abyss, which is the sort of the chaos, the pre-Socratics are
also the name for that descent into Aetna, right.
Into the, the bowels of the volcano, that that's the, the lure is to respond to a scent
with descent.
And to me, that's how I think of the feminist interventions is that by and large, there has
been a response against the idealization by recourse to bodies.
And, uh, and in this case, it seems to me like bodies themselves aren't going to get
you there any more than ideas are going to get you there.
Right.
That the, the surface, uh, that he's interested in, and that's where I have a really hard time
with that, with the surface thing, because to me, I'm like, okay, I get the bodies and
I get why you go, but I also take your point, Nathaniel, which is if bodies, if bodies are
thought as not ideas, right, they're, they're still locked in descent.
They're still locked into descent in that regard.
And so the, the, the problem then becomes, uh, thinking, uh, thinking, uh, frankly, an
immaterial body, right?
Like that, or the, the necessary immateriality of the body.
Yeah.
Or bodies without organs, which would be like, yeah, that becomes the tricky thing.
Right.
On the surface, whatever points get coordinated together, that's a body, right?
And it's not organized categorically and hierarchically.
It's like, no, no, that, that particular set of relationships between these, how many
ever singular points, that's a body.
And it produces its own function.
It admits its own singularities.
It's just very hard.
So for instance, to me, when I think pedagogically, for instance, and I, I've been going through
this with a couple of students in the last roughly week or so, it's very hard for me not
to think in terms of depth of like, look, you got to go deeper into this.
You got to, you know, for instance, it's, it's difficult for me not to think of my enthymeme
exercise as a more in-depth exploration of, of the enthymeme, right?
Like let's, by unpacking the enthymeme, we are adding depth to it, right?
Like, it's very hard for me to simply think of that as associative circuits, um, that aren't
organized around some model of descent or ascent, you know?
The fact that they never stop should be a clue, right?
Yeah.
The fact that they never stabilize should be a clue that the infinite descent is creating
a flat surface.
Well, but that, but so for instance, the infinite descent is like there are rooms behind rooms
beneath Etna, right?
Like that's, you know, what you find, and it's the same is true with the ascent as well,
right?
You don't actually get to, forms don't have existence, right?
So in both the ascent and descent, it's an infinite process.
So I don't think there is like, well, you know, because it's infinite, that means it's
lateral and that means it's surface.
It's because to me, infinite can be like meta, the meta move is infinitely ascending.
You never get to the point outside of having to make the self-conscious reflection, right?
And the same is true in terms of depth, right?
There's always another cavern beneath the cavern that you just found.
So the fact of its infinite quality is to me, you know, not what realigns that ascent
and descent mode onto a horizontal axis.
I mean, but there's a difference between like a depth of thinking and a precision of thinking,
right?
I mean, cause you could think of it like, cause that's what we always talk about with writing.
Like you want to be as precise as possible.
I wouldn't necessarily think of that as getting beneath or deep below the enthyme, right?
So if like you start with a question of taste, I like this art or I like this type of music
and then you unravel, you know, the, the associations that create that taste formation, that wouldn't
necessarily be a question of depth.
It's just like precise analysis of that, of the initial question.
You just use the word unravel, right?
So you just use unravel it horizontally.
Unravel doesn't have to be a depth though, right?
Yeah.
Just kind of unraveling points on, you're getting to the inside from the outside.
A ball of string doesn't have to find another word, find another word for it then.
No, it's an, it's an infinite, it's an infinite unraveling.
I, I, I grant you that you don't arrive at, but, but what you're doing is trying to get
unraveling at those little threads are getting hooked onto points and then you are sort of
like on, on a surface of things, you are now creating an idiosyncratic on like unraveling.
There is, you're not, you're just tossing it over your shoulder.
Well, I guess that's one way of unraveling things.
Hey, you got, you want the flat plane.
I'm trying to fucking put it on there.
I know.
We have, this is Devil's advocate, John.
We have another, okay, it might help us to actually go to, cause this is like one of
the, I mean, we have not had a ton of visuals for the surface for a while now and we finally
get another one on, on 133, right?
The fogged up window pane.
And I wonder if that's going to help us understand, right?
If we want to get to that flat plane, does this help us?
I don't know.
Like, like a fogged up window pane on which one can write with one's finger.
Yeah.
Where is that?
133.
On 133.
What's the, the, yeah.
Cause we haven't had one of these in a while, right?
I remember the mist like in the beginning, right?
Yeah.
I also like the tick and the louse example.
I don't know enough about ticks and louses, right?
Like, um, I, I wrote this, the note, like do ticks and louses move enough to, to, um, uh,
cause they seem to be pretty sedentary critters.
And then I realized paratactically speaking, they get moved all over the place, right?
Yeah.
Jump on something, burrow on in and then they're transported.
They're simply associative.
Yeah.
That's, that's smart.
And I got Lyme disease from one of them, so I'd rather not, yeah, yeah.
I'd rather not hang out with ticks.
I'm wearing my, I'm wearing my Lyme dream shirt just for you, man.
Exactly.
That's so generous.
Okay.
Can we read this, just this last paragraph then?
The one that kind of points it out then?
Do it, bud.
The cynics and the Stoics establish themselves and wrap themselves up with the surface, the
curtain, the carpet, and the mantle.
The double sense of the surface, the continuity of the reverse and right sides, replace height
and depth.
There is nothing behind the curtain except unnameable mixtures, nothing above the carpet
except empty sky.
Sense appears and is played out at the surface, at least if one knows how to mix it properly,
in such a way that it forms letters of dust.
It is like a fogged-up window pane on which one can write with one's own finger.
The staff-blow philosophy of the cynics and the Stoics replaces the hammer-blow philosophy.
The philosopher is no longer the being of the caves, nor Plato's soul or bird, but rather
the animal which is on a level with the surface, a tick or a louse.
The philosophical symbol is no longer the Platonic wing or Empedocles' led sandal, but the reversible
cloak of Antisthenes and Diogenes, the staff and the mantle, as in the case of Hercules with
his club and lion skin.
What are we to call this new philosophical operation insofar as it opposes at once Platonic
conversion and pre-Socratic subversion?
Perhaps we can call it perversion, which at least befits the system of provocations of
this new type of philosopher.
If it is true that perversion implies an extraordinary art of surfaces.
Isn't that fun?
I mean, yeah, no, no.
It's just fun when it's just like, I mean, you can just read him playing association pong.
It's like, okay, what would be the equivalent of Plato's wing?
Oh, you know, like he's just throwing shit out there and it's just, it is fun.
And I agree with Caddy.
I love that the fogged up window pane on which you write with your finger as a way of indicating.
And look, I get the notion of the ontology of surface, right?
Obviously, you know, like that's something that obviously interests me a great deal.
I just don't, I guess I'm just not clear on how to distinguish that from the ascent and
the descent, right?
Because it seems to me that the claim would be something more like, or maybe the later Deleuze's
claim would be, it's nothing but writing on window panes, right?
Plato's writing on window panes.
It's not that the pre-Socratics were doing this depth model and the Platonics were doing
this transcendence model.
They were all writing on window panes.
That's all there is.
Right.
But it depends on how you see the ascent and the descent.
And if the ascent and the descent only travel up one line, then you don't have enough dimensions.
You have to add the second dimension to the thing where you can make the, it's not just
going up or down.
You have to add the lateral.
But that's, so that's, so how do you get from the non, you know, especially because lines
aren't, they have no thickness, right?
I mean, in the geometric conception, right?
So how do you get from that up and down to even just a, once you move a micromolecule to
one side or the other, the whole diagram is completely changed.
This is what Nate was getting to is that like in, in the example of the anthem meme, as soon
as you attach the, the, the next sentence to it, you know, I don't like it because it's
boring.
And then you try to say, all right, now I'm going to go just straight down vertically in
one line and say, I have pre subsumed an equation between interestingness and goodness, right?
And that's, and I think that the move would have to be, that is not a straight line.
That is adding some width to it, right?
That, that is, that, that is happening at the level of the surface.
You might think that you're drilling down and simply rounding the thing or drilling up and
simply finding the rule that governs it.
Right.
You're, even if you're moving that modicon of, of, of, of, of distance, you know, to the
right, uh, transversely, you've created a plane.
So, so you'd say using, uh, um, Nate's example, like there are two ways to unravel string.
One is to try to get to the interior of the string, which of course will turn out to be
absent the great onion example.
But that to me was exactly the romantic irony, right?
Like is that no matter how much you unravel string, you're not going to get to the center
of the string, but you're still unraveling.
So in any case, there is the way that is unraveling.
And then there's the way that's just putting string in different places, right?
Like that, that second way is that surface idea is even though you think you're unraveling
and trying to get to a center, which of course will turn out to be absent, the fact of an
absent center is sort of irrelevant to that.
Like even if there were a center, it wouldn't matter.
It would just be another move in the game so that there would be only styles of laying out
of laying out string on the surface.
Right.
Exactly.
So all you're doing is moving the string here or there makes a big, makes a big, makes
all the difference.
Right.
Yeah.
The title of this episode will be Two Ways of Unraveling Strings.
I did have a student a couple of years ago in the medicine theories about writing course.
After I did like, you know, I, I, I think we were doing Derrida and I was like laying out
the very sort of like logical structured way of thinking grammatically about it.
And then I did, I ended up being looking like a bunch of different lines that intersect each
other in particular ways.
One of my students, I just wrote me, he's like, I think I really understood something today,
but the only way I can articulate it is this truth is a ball of string or truth is a ball
of yarn.
The tick, the tick, the louse suddenly makes much more sense to me that, I mean, as
a figure of, of Hercules, I mean, like what, it sounds crazy associationism to think about
the tick, the louse and Hercules, but like Hercules is the paratactic iterative wanderer,
the nomad that, that moves from, you know, to the left, to the right.
He meanders, not aimlessly, but because, you know, some impulse is driving him this way.
He's got to have, he has a task up here.
He's got one trial here.
He's got to take care of it, but he's got to go to the next trial and it's not procedural
along a linear path.
He's coming through, he's grasshopper.
He's, he's traveling out from here to there.
The tick, the louse, they get attached to, you know, the, the, the host body and they get
taken here, there, and they're transmitting their Lyme disease and that, you know, yeah.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
I simply can't, by the way, gets Nate to get his vaccine earlier.
It's true.
So maybe actually beneficial in the long run.
I, I, I, sorry, I can't endorse a tick because of my prior, because of my prior encounters.
Have you guys read the cartoon, The Tick?
Because it's absolutely fantastic.
I haven't.
I think this is, I think this is why Diogenes actually works like perfectly, right?
Because Plato, you know, called Diogenes, Socrates, if Socrates were mad.
And so we think about, we think about Socrates' movements out in public and we think about
him being like, all right, yeah, let's go walk to this place, right?
But if we're thinking about the tick and the louse, it's Diogenes and he's just here doing
his thing over here.
And like, you know, like the movement tracks, right?
The movement totally tracks.
Right.
Yeah.
There is a passage in Thousand Plateaus where he talks about the tick in, in positive terms.
And he's like, the tick basically has two moves in life, which is smell or detect the scent
of a mammal, one, two, fall, right?
That's it, right?
Like, I detect the scent, therefore I fall and I land on whatever I land on.
And then if I landed on the mammal that I detected, things work out pretty great for me.
If not, then I probably get stepped on.
Right.
Damn.
So fall on the surface.
Well, I was going to say too that I've been really trying to think through that fogged-up
windowpane example too.
And I had a really hard time thinking of that without recourse to transcendence, because,
you know, when you, when you're writing on the windowpane, it's like, you know, you're
repeating this transcendent, this transcendent code, right?
This transcendent logic now gets instantiated on, on the windowpane.
And I'm reading that a little bit differently now that it doesn't have to do, it doesn't
have to be language.
It just, it's the differentiating mark that, you know, you, you, you, even if it's a line,
right now, suddenly on that plane, I've created spatialized relationships with each other that
don't need to correspond, decide, you know, what they don't need to accurately or fail to
accurately represent some higher form.
It is, there's no failure or success.
It's interesting though, that you even bring that up by saying you, you, you, you reverted
into the second person there.
He's not in the second person, right?
He's saying once, right?
And I think that that's, that's that individual in general move that I think avoids maybe the
transcendental thing that you're, you're having an issue with.
I don't know, but I think that's interesting.
Yeah.
No, I think that's a good, I mean, that gets all totally into all of his stuff about the
importance of the impersonal and the, but like the impersonal through the generic, you
know, like, I mean, I'm thinking about his becoming intense chapter of like, you know,
becoming, you know, a, like a woman or an animal, right?
That, that, that, um, yeah, indistinction of the, the distinct instinct and distinction
of the, I can also see why that, that example is appealing to Deleuze, the writing on the, the
fog or on the windowpane, uh, because of the, the impermanence of it pretty clearly.
So there's, there's simply no stability to that writing, right?
That you're not, there's no telos to writing on a windowpane, right?
I mean, you're not going to, you're not going to become famous as an author writing on a
window pane.
You're not going to, you know.
You got a Banksy type of project going here, man.
This sounds like, okay.
It's true, it's true.
Maybe you could.
Banksy is a delusional artist, though.
Right.
There's going to be windowpanes all over Manhattan.
Beach art.
Yeah.
Beach art's become a thing.
Well, it's also, I mean, it's also, and this feeds Nate's point there of like, the surface
isn't a surface for writing, right?
Like even the existence of the surface itself is something that only comes into being when
this weather differential has happened between the inside and the outside.
It's not, so, so not only the thing that you write, but even the surface itself, I mean,
not only is it temporary, but it's, it only comes into existence temporarily and it also
disappears as Nate's pointing out, but it's coming into existence.
It's like, hey, just happenstance.
Yeah.
Different differential relation between the inside and the outside, you know, this also makes
the perversion stuff more precise to me that, that, you know, it seems that the perversion
happens when that transversal movement happens.
Like when you, there's any kind of transversal move a lot like that, that, that makes the vertical
not just a line, right?
As soon as you introduce that second dimension at all, then it is not the pure grounding or
the pure vertical move and you've breached some kind of supposed protocol, right?
Cause if, if you move even just the modicon of, of, of, of, of, of distance away from, you
know, the, the grounding line, you've perverted the proper lineage of the thing, right?
That, that, that, that stabilizes, you know, whatever the object of investigation is.
If you, in other words, like this is, this is why Plato hates examples, right?
That the examples are contaminating that if I say, what is virtue, then I point to a virtuous
person.
It's going to introduce nefarious elements that virtue might be one of those things, but
it's also introducing other things that I need to find the purity of the virtue itself.
I cannot allow any transversal movement.
I have to like move precisely up or in the grounding, we'll have to move precisely down.
And if there's any kind of transversal, it's, it's a perversion of that thing.
I still, I mean, I still come back to like, you know, just, and this is, I do this all
the time and I, it's an annoying feature of me, but like, I, I do always want to say at
the end of that, like, I agree, I get the need to make those distinctions, but I also then
want to say that platonic ascent then is just a version of surface.
That's all it is.
And the reg and the sort of regulations that dictate its movement, they're also surfaces,
which is to say there's, there's nothing but writing on window panes.
So there's nothing from which to distinguish it, you know?
And so in the ways that the distinctions work here, we've got ascent, descent, surface.
Cool.
We can understand what surface is because we know it's not ascent and we know it's not
descent.
And I always, and I get the need to go through that pedagogy, like that progression of here's
ascent, here's descent, not that surface.
But I also think there's a hugely important next move, which is by the way, ascent and
descent were always surfaces, right?
Like that next move, that next move is, is, and, and, and you don't get that all the time
in Doulouse.
You don't all the time.
But the thing is, is that that second move requires the prior position of the slash.
Their moves, it's becoming, it's not, it's not that the third move is the right one.
You couldn't do the third move.
I mean, this is to Nate's point about Hegel, right?
You couldn't do the third move had you not done the first two, or rather the third move
would have a completely different sense.
If you just said, well, Plato is all about surfaces.
If you just start with that, you know, that position, it has a really different sense than
if you get to that position, right?
But this reminds me of some of the stuff that we were talking about with Hegel.
And my point was like, look, multiplicity looks different from the perspective of negation
and negation looks different from the perspective of multiplicity, right?
And so ascent and descent don't look like ascent and descent from the perspective of the
flat plane.
Of the surface, right.
And from the perspective of ascent and descent, the flat plane just looks like air, right?
Right.
But I guess, I mean, so maybe I'm a Platonist of surfaces in that regard, because I'm like,
that's the only ontological position, that the ascent and descent, in other words, every
time someone claims the meta-reflective move, I mean, people claim it all the time, but they're
not doing it.
You can't do it.
Or rather, another way of saying it is, yes, they are doing it, because what doing it means
is only...
Is to move across the flat plane, right?
So they are doing it.
They're not wrong, right?
So, I mean, to me, that second move, or that third move, like that final move, it just
sort of wipes everything clean in a way that maybe that's not the right way of saying it,
but it just, it smears the very distinctions that got you to that point in a way that to
me is hugely philosophically important.
That's why I always had these devil's advocate kind of moments.
But what it does, I totally agree, but what it does do is it positions you to hold on to
an ontological primary, right?
Right, that's right, surface.
All of the smearing is only possible given the ontological primacy of the ontological,
of the flat plane of ontology, of the surface, right?
And what I totally feel comfortable doing, because what it, because what it, but it's super,
it's super violent, but it's violent in a particular way, because it doesn't allow me to say,
you are wrong, or your thing isn't a thing, it allows me to say, your thing is a thing that
does potentially interesting, potentially violent things, but it only can be articulated from
my position, right?
And by the way, my position is not validated.
But see, but then, okay, but I was going to say, then you're going back into the position
of this, of the romantic irony, right?
Like, as if.
No, no, no, not subjectivist, not a subjectivist, but from the position of the flat plane, which
is, which isn't my subjective position so much as, that's very important.
And that's where, that's where he says, is that the problem with the romantic version
is that singularities get trapped in individuals and persons, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, no, this is not subjectivist, this is to say that, you know, if you think,
if you're thinking, like, error is not a, like, error is not true in the, from the perspective
Of error, but error is true from the perspective of the flat plane that sees error as a way
of, of, of charting and patch on the spot plane.
I thought you were saying error.
I didn't realize you were saying error.
I was like, what the fuck is this error?
I thought you were saying error too.
I know.
I thought it was like an, I thought he was going to make an Air Jordan reference.
It was going to be all about hoops.
You know, by the way, I looked up perversion, just the etymology of it, the action of turning
aside from truth, corruption, distortion, but, but from perverse synonym, the, the denominative
perversio, the Latin, a turning about, right?
So I mean, it does seem to like have from that spatial sense of, you know, it is, it is
a turn, it is a trope of, of moving.
I'm going to have to write, wait, this is like from heliotropism to perversion.
And this is going to be, I also think that, um, that Deleuze's choice here and basically
in his whole oeuvre or whatever, like, cause his two main enemies are Plato and Hegel and
he never grants them.
He never does the move that you're talking about, John, where he eventually grants them
like, uh, at least provisional sort of like, you know, emplacement in his ontology.
He basically says like, they're out and he, he does that over and over again.
And I'm thinking it has as much to do with like ethics and the potential for like his
radical political thought, it has as much to do about that as it does to do as it does
with the, the formal philosophical system, you know, like, because Deleuze is so interested
in the possibility of political revolution or of like some sort of ethical turn.
And he seems to think that the motivations that are embedded in Plato's system or, you know,
the hierarchy that's embedded in Hegel's dialectic, that those are, those are dangerous and they
need to be, um, sort of routed, you know?
And so I don't, I don't agree with you on Plato because we'll, we'll get to it.
I mean, the, one of the appendix here, Plato in the simulacrum basically says Plato is the
one who pointed out the means for the reversal of Platonism.
So yeah, you're right.
Yeah.
But for Hegel, Hegel at least, he never, he never grants it to Hegel.
I agree with you on Hegel, but I do think that I really, I mean, as we talk, like that's,
to me, that's a tonal one that he's just not, he's, he's, I get that he's gone to bat
for it and I kind of get a sense of why, but yeah, I agree with that on, on Hegel.
So again, let me hear your, let me hear your hatred for 17.
Well, I just fucking hated reading it.
Like just the experience of reading, just the, just literally the experience of reading
the 17th was awful.
Right.
And, and I felt like at every turn, I was like, wait, what the fuck did I just read?
What the fuck did I just read?
Right.
And then I read 18th, I read 19th, both I love, you know, and then I realized at the end
of 19th that I would not have gotten as much as I did from the 18th and 19th had it not
been for starting with the 17th.
And then I was like, whoa, because we, cause we arbitrarily chose 17th, 18th, 19th.
Right.
But for some reason we had, I personally had to read the 17th and then the 18th and the
19th to, to, to, to fully appreciate both of the 18th and 19th and the 17th after the
18th and 19th, it was kind of a mind trip.
I did not understand the 17th.
I mean, I still don't think I understand it, but I did not have, I didn't have a capacity
to think through it until I read 19th.
And I hate, like, I felt like an undergraduate again, reading theory for the first time.
It's like, I know that every word in that sentence was English, but I don't understand how any
of them relate to each other.
Exactly.
It was super technical and it seems to be kind of rooted in like an analytic tradition more
than his more continental, like bent.
Like there was just a bunch, there was a bunch of, uh, like usage of the language of true
and false.
And like, here's the true problem.
Here's the false problem philosophy in 17.
And just based on the typical lexicon of Deleuze, I was like, how does any of this make any
sense?
And I, and at times I think he's just outlining problematics of other people.
Like I was just all mixed up here.
You know what I mean?
Well, so that, that made sense to me in my third reading of it, the way that the truth
and the fall falsity work there is that like, you have to think like, so when he, so on one
20, when he's talking about error, right.
And he's so, so that, that first full paragraph, it appears that sense in his organization of the
aleatory and singular points, uh, problems in question, series and displacements is double
generative.
Not only does it engender the logical proposition with, with its determinant, uh, uh, dimensions,
denotation, manifestation, and signification, it engenders also the objective correlates of
this proposition, which were themselves first produced as ontological propositions, the
denotated, the manifested, and the signified, right?
Uh, so like basically, look, you have the, the sort of the logical order of things, the acts
of, of, um, uh, denotation, manifestation, and signification.
And then you get like these bodily mixtures that I get produced as effects of these things
that denotated, the manifested, the signified, right.
And then, so, and those are brought to the surface together, right.
That they aren't, they aren't two of two separate orders.
Right.
And then he says the lack of synchronicity and the blurring between these two aspects of
Genesis explains a phenomenon like error.
Like, uh, since some, something denotated, for example, may be given, uh, in an ontological
proposition, which does not correspond to the logical proposition under consideration.
Error, however, is a very artificial notion, an abstract philosophical concept, right.
Which is like, look, you can have the, the denotating and the denotated, right.
Not totally line up with each other.
And that's perfectly fine, right.
That's, I mean, that is the move of the Stoics say, like, you know, doing the totally random
thing in response to the question, like some kind of question by showing that like, look,
these things can be brought together.
They can be linked and they can not follow the sort of the logical order of, of, of what
you expect.
He's saying that the whole notion of error only comes about if you presume that these
things need to, like, it's when they come together in a good sense, then they're right.
And when they come together that breach that good sense, then, then they've errored.
And what he's saying is like, however they are brought together produces a sense.
Right, right.
They are, but, but they are not necessary as such.
Right.
And, and they are not, and they, they are not foundational as such for sure.
Which goes back to like that, that Zen, um, example in 19 where he's like, look, look, saying,
you know, if you have a staff or a cane, I'm going to give you one.
That seems like nonsense.
That seems like you've, you've actually denotated two, you've, you've, you've marked two objects
in a relationship to each other that cannot exist.
If you have one, I can't give you one.
If you don't have one, I can't take it away from you.
It's like, no, it's that the particular way in which those propositions align with each other
produces an imminent sense between the propositions, not one that is standing over it, governing it,
which is why he's always like talking about sense as a mist, as something that's like.
As hovering.
A covering, right?
No, hovering.
He says hovering.
Oh, hovering, a hovering, yeah.
Which always trips me up, but yeah.
It can't touch it, but it can't be too far up.
It can't be too close, right?
Right.
It has to like.
It's like that little, it's like when you're a little kid and you're like, I'm not touching
you.
But then truth comes back in, in a really interesting way, in the form of the problem.
Yeah, that's what I, okay, that's what I was mostly talking about, yeah.
Yeah.
Right, because it's like, all right, true, false, toss that aside.
That's just like, that's, that's not what's going on here.
Then suddenly brings in this language of the truth, which I think is going to be the truth
of the singularity, right?
Yeah.
And the problematic sets out a field of conditions that include its solution, but also, but it
clears out the space for existence or a kind of life within that problematic field.
And the idiosyncrasy or the singularity of that thing is the truth, right?
And there's no chance of erroring within that truth.
Right.
There, there are more or less precise ways to outline a problematic, right?
So there are false problematics in the sense that, like, for example, Plato's to some extent
is a, is a false problematic because he's actually outlining the true and the false.
Whereas for Deleuze on the, with the flat ontology, there's only singularities, however you want
to phrase it, there are no simply true or false propositions or orders of being or whatever.
It reminds me of like, this would be kind of a, an Hegelian problematic or like a critique
of, let's say like a certain social justice initiatives where you'd say, okay, racism is a
problem.
I mean, very clearly.
But the way that we're trying to attack it, right?
It's, it's sort of, we're attacking secondary problems where the root for Hegel would be
like in an actual, like fascistic tendency in the subject, right?
So it's like the appropriative mechanism, negation itself has racism almost like embedded in it.
So when you attack the surface problems or those secondary problems, you're not treating
the, the primary or true problematic, which is kind of like how we engage at a basic level.
So I, I don't know that.
Yeah.
I don't know if that.
I like that example.
I think I would replace the language of, of the false, right?
With the language of, or it may be even precision with haphazardness, right?
Is that, you know, I see this problem and then now I'm going to counter it with that thing,
which now is going to create a sense between the two of them, but it's kind of a clumsy
sentence.
It's kind of a haphazardly thrown together sentence, right?
I get this with my students all the time, trying to teach them this or that theory.
It's like, well, now we have to do this, right?
Like, whoa, that's a, sure, that's one way you can respond to it, but it's a little clumsy,
maybe a little fascistic, right?
Right, right, right.
Yeah.
But yeah, that was just my way of thinking through like the, the relationship between the
problematic and then the secondary problems or the false problems that he kind of outlines
in this, in 17.
Well, so let's read maybe just 121.
Is that cool?
Sure.
Yeah.
All right.
So the very bottom of 120.
So the, the relation between the problem and its conditions defines sense as the truth
of the problem as such.
I found that to be really helpful that, that the problem or sorry, the relationship between
the problem and its conditions.
So that relationship is the, is sense as the truth of the problem as such.
So the, the, the field that the problem lays out is the truth of sense.
It may happen that the, that conditions remain insufficiently determined, or on the other
hand, that they are overdetermined in such a manner that the problem may turn out to be
a false problem.
As for the determination of conditions, it implies on the one hand, a space of nomad distribution
in which singularities are distributed, topos.
I love that idea of, that sense of topos.
Yeah, I remember right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I'm like, oh, topos is the distribution of singularities.
Different from locus.
On the other hand, it implies a time of decomposition whereby this space is subdivided into subspaces.
Each one of these subspaces is successfully defined by the adjunction of new points, ensuring the
progression and complete determination of the domain under consideration.
There is always a space which condenses, condenses and precipitates singularities, just as there
is always a time which progressively completes the event through fragments of future past and
events.
The way I saw this is that, like, you know, the, the way that singularities get hooked together,
like into a problematic, that problematic condenses those singularities into its own body, into
its own organ.
This is like, this is the production of a sense body, of a sensory body.
This is why people often, quite often believe that the solution does not allow the problem
to subsist and that it assigns to it retrospectively the status of a subjective moment, which is
necessarily transcended as soon as the solution is found.
The opposite though is the case.
It's basically like, Hey, the typical way of thinking about a problem is like, once you
find the solution, the problem is dissolved in the solution.
And as a personal thing is just like, when I figure out the solution, the problem dissolves.
But right.
It kind of makes me think like if we had, if we had a false problem, it kind of actually
makes me think about humor as opposed to irony because, um, there's something about irony
that he's critiquing in terms of Socratic irony, certainly where like the questions themselves
as part of that kind of dialectic are wrong to begin with.
So if like, if we're thinking about, if we're thinking about a false problem, like I'm not
even, I'm not even thinking about, I'm not even thinking about the result as much as the
start to, you know, it's like, I don't know where I'm going with it.
So what would make a false problem would be a sort of like an insufficient determination
or an overdetermination.
And in both of those cases, it seems to me that what, what is happening is that the problematic
is not charting out a sufficiently livable space.
Right.
And I think that like what we're talking about here is the possibility of, of, of life operating
with, on, on a surface.
And that, you know, the, yeah, to go back to Nate's point.
Yeah.
But they, but sort of like the insufficiently determined problematic would fall into the
ground and be caught like into the digestive ground that, that gets subsumed.
Like there's not enough determination.
There's too much nonsense for there any to be, for any life to be able to operate and differentiate
itself.
Right.
But the overdetermined problem is going to run into the problem of the heights where
like it, like the, the, or the, or the, the problem of, you know, um, making everything
static.
Like now nothing can, now nothing can breathe.
Nothing.
Now there's no genesis.
Yeah.
I've hypothesized this thing.
Right.
And so the, so that the, the, the, the, the field of the problematic needs to be sufficiently
determined that you can create space and movement between things, but not so overly determined
that everything grounds to a halt.
And so that the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the.